[Music]
good morning everybody and welcome to
the first ever parallel Society Congress
brought to you by logos please can we
have a round of applause for everyone
for turning up today welcome
welcome it is fantastic to see so many
familiar faces in the audience today
some new ones as well and we're United
by a common interest that is the
future of post and parallel State
governance now if that statement means
nothing to you and it confuses you don't
worry that makes two of us I'm also here
to learn today my background is in
Bitcoin and as a form of uh Bitcoin is a
form of sovereign money and that's the
lens through which we are going to
approach the Congress today or at least
I am you will have your own lens and
your own approach to the Congress today
and I encourage you to explore that to
ask questions and to be curious to
introduce myself my name is Joe Nakamoto
I am a reporter um I've been reporting
about the Bitcoin and crypto space since
2019 for the likes ofcoin Telegraph
Bitcoin magazine the guardian and the
BBC yes they even let me talk about
Bitcoin on the
BBC I look forward to getting to know
you all today um as your stage host so
feel free to ask me questions I'm here
to have fun with you to make you smile
and to ensure that you have an amazing
time at the parallel Society Congress
first thing to say is a massive thank
you you all for making the trip out to
Bangkok this morning it's a beautiful
city it's a City full of Finance full of
Entrepreneurship and new ideas new and
Big Ideas that I hope we're going to
explore today because you will be
hearing from some of the most Brilliant
Minds in the blockchain space and me be
they experts pioneers and innovators
maybe we'll even hear from Satoshi
Nakamoto themselves you can't prove it
unless you're HBO
you did watch the documentary okay
that's good great to kick things off I
want to ask you a very quick question so
since we are here to discuss Network
States and parallel societies please
raise your hand if you would join a
network State tomorrow if it aligned
with your
ideals okay that's about 2third of the
room lovely welcome welcome the rest of
the room will work on you now keep your
hand up if you'd be ready to give up
your current past thought just wait for
a digital one for a digital one assigned
by that new network state I'm putting my
hand down I've got an Irish passport and
that took me a long time to get but you
guys brilliant these are the guys to ask
questions you for sure because today
we're diving into these kind of
questions rethinking nationhood
rethinking sovereignty and crucially
what it means to
belong because the mission of parallel
societies it's a gathering it's uniting
it's an exploration of what what comes
next what might succeed the 400y old
nation state model which as we can
probably feel in all of our respective
countries isn't working as well as we'd
hoped how can we unlock the potential
that's been lying dormant in outdated
governance
structures this movement isn't just
about resistance there's enough
resistance in the world already it's
about construction it's about creativity
it's about building so today we'll EXP
explore how parallel Societies or
network states can provide spaces where
people organize where they live and
where they Thrive outside of those
traditional or conventional
Frameworks one quick favor I just want
to ask of you guys this Congress was
this Congress sorry was co-curated with
our partners and collaborators and
crucially you guys as well to uh to help
navigate this territory that is a little
bit unknown and speaking of those
partners and collaborators you may see
on the board behind me all of the
collaborators and sponsors who made this
possible so I just want you all to
recognize them and uh to thank them and
that is build cities Charter cities
Institute Clos funding the commons feel
free to applaud as well thank you to
that person codex key card The Institute
of free technology waku logos operators
zoo Village Georgia shanhai wo RNs ID
women in web 3 privacy dark fi and rail
gun one more time can we give them a big
round of applause there they are so
thank you to these
guys so we've introduced myself we've
broken the eyes we've thanked the
sponsors now it's time just to help you
guys navigate the day ahead so a few
housekeeping tips the full agenda is on
pc. logos. that's pc. logos. full agenda
is there if not there will also be um
this shown just behind that screen
actually as you enter the room um for my
tips I'm most looking forward to seeing
the first panel discussion of the day
with Jared and the last panel of the day
so don't leave early the last panel is
actually with Michelle Bowens from the P
the founder of the peer-to-peer
Foundation as well as David Casey and
the founder of gitcoin so some absolute
gigar brains to end the day there are
also lightning talks taking place on the
floors below us lightning talks lives up
to the name the idea is that you can ask
quick questions you can engage in a more
informal Manner and ask questions about
the future of these governance
structures toilets ground and first
floors water is in the Chill Zone and
coffee is available at the machines on
each floor as well as at the coffee or
the cafe rather on the ground floor if
you want some free merch so why I'm
carrying this does anyone want a free
hat raise your hand if you want a free
hat there you are you the first going to
check that over to you just to prove it
is free they are giving out free merch
today on the floor just below us um the
logos operators are also there offering
custom key card Hardware wallets if
you're interested you must take custody
of your crypto if you haven't already
lunch is from 12:30 to 1:30 drinks and
dinner from 7: till 9: and there's also
a surprise this evening which you should
definitely stick around for a local band
is playing I'm not going to say who it
is yet to keep the surprise nice and
juicy um but it's worth sticking around
for I'm really looking forward to it
okay we're almost done final thing from
me piece of advice from me to Yours
Truly is just to be curious be daring be
courageous this day will pass the blink
of an eye is going to pass way too
quickly so please grab this opportunity
and seize it with two hands you must get
involved you must take this opportunity
um now that it's in front of yourselves
[Music]